How to maintain success?
So this is a great question that I got from one of my readers
NOVREHS who wrote in to say
“Thanks for the video Evan.
I got a question.
Is it possible to do a video based
on how you can maintain success?”
So this is a great question
and if you want to maintain success
the key is you need to evolve and innovate.
A lot of times, entrepreneurs,
they start a business, they start seeing some success
they start getting sales
they start getting market penetration
they start getting market share
and then you see the companies start to plateau.
You know, you’re here, you’re just stable
and then you start seeing the company decline.
And this happens with most companies.
Look at how many companies have lasted a hundred years
or longer and there aren’t that many.
Most companies shut down, they fail
they can’t transfer to another generation
they can’t maintain their success
because they don’t evolve and innovate.
The reality is your market is going to change, right?
You discover a secret, right
you discover a whole other market
something that is missing
and you fill it with your product or service.
That’s great and it works for a while
but you’ve got to change it over time, right
you’ve got to continue to add to it because
the market is going to change
and if you don’t keep up with it
you’re company’s going to suffer.
You can’t keep doing the same thing
over and over and over and over and over again, okay?
Look at Blockbuster, right, they had the video stores.
You know, go there, rent a video, bring the DVD back
and then came along the internet
and then came along Netflix
and Blockbuster had the chance to buy Netflix
and that deal didn’t work out
and now Blockbuster’s out of business.
They had a great concept.
It was working for a long time
they made a lot of money but they didn’t innovate or evolve
and the company went under really quickly
and that’s what happens to a lot of companies.
So to get to a successful point is hard enough
but to maintain it is harder
because you need to keep innovating and evolving.
When you don’t do that
2 things happen
one, as I mention your company suffers, right.
You stop coming up with new ideas
and your company starts to stagnate, flat sales
then stars to decline
but the second part is you become bored.
You know as an entrepreneur, entrepreneurs,
we’re addicted to the new, right?
We come up with new ideas
we’re the visionaries
we have this idea of what we want to create
and then it’s fun to put it into place
and to start to see it grow.
We don’t want to just maintain this boring company.
We want to come up with new things
and so, when you’re not doing that as a company
it hurts your business but it also hurts you
like it hurts your soul as an entrepreneur
not to be coming up with new things
to help your customers out.
So you want to maintain success?
Continue to evolve and innovate.
Believe.
For those of you watching,
love to know what you think.
Leave a comment below,
click on the link in the description to support me.
Click on my face, subscribe to the channel.
Thank you so much, I’ll see you soon.